tu peux le fermer l'enroulé c'est un
tapis tu peux te protéger avec du
néoprène c'est fait à base de
combinaison de plongée tu mets le tapis
au sol l'humidité passe pas ça se
nettoie à l'eau j'ai eu l'idée tant que
pêcheur sous-marin de transformer des
combinaisons
usagées destinés à être jeté
en tapis pour les SDF
[Musique]
alors là on est dans l'atelier découpage
on prend les combinaisons
usagés
on fait une découpe avec un patron il
nous faut 4 eaux de combinaisons pour
faire un tapis et après pour les bas il
nous faut trois bas et demi pour faire
un tapis on a récupéré les bras pour
faire les coussins et après tout le
reste a été découpé en petits copeaux
pour faire le coussin qui est
directement là dans les combinaisons de
plongée on a deux fermetures sur les
combinaisons et en fait même ça on les
récupère c'est que du recyclage
aujourd'hui c'est du recyclage solidaire
Mathieu c'est notre Coluche non c'est
notre Coluche thémère mais voilà dès
qu'il y a une proposition et qu'on peut
aider par rapport à notre passion on le
fait volontiers
on a tous les mêmes les mêmes
convictions aussi je suis vraiment fier
de mon équipe tous les ateliers qu'on a
pu faire c'est un travail de trois mois
trois mois travail tous les tous les
samedi matin à être là à travailler le
néoprène on n'est pas des professionnels
on a appris dans le tas mais je pense
que le résultat est là et voilà une de
plus j'ai fait une maraude et en
distribuant en fait ma soupe de poisson
qu'on a pêché nous-même je me suis
aperçu que les SDF étaient directement
sur des du carton et n'avait rien en
fait donc en parlant avec eux ils
avaient un problème de froid et vu que
je suis pêcheur sous-marin je me suis
dit mais attends moi j'ai une
combinaison qui me protège du froid donc
ce que je vais faire c'est que je vais
récupérer mes combinaisons et je vais en
faire des tapis et des coussins pour les
SDF voilà pour essayer de la réchauffer
le corps et le coeur je pensais que
j'allais faire 5 6 tapis pour moi
c'était 5 6 personnes qui allaient
dormir sur les tapis au lieu d'être au
sol et en fait aujourd'hui on sort une
trentaine 30 35 il y avait un engouement
dans toute la France j'ai reçu pas mal
de combinaisons avec des félicitations
avec des mots le but c'est que les les
voisins du trottoir puissent avoir leur
tapis et leur coussins pour l'hiver la
première cause de mortalité des des SDF
c'est le froid des fois on ferme les
yeux on passe à côté on dit même pas un
bonjour tandis qu'en fait ça peut être
vous ça peut être moi ça peut être mes
collègues ça peut être n'importe qui
ils sont là pour récupérer les tapis les
coussins tout ce qu'on a fait en fait
pour distribuer directement auprès de
des voisins du trottoir sont très très
connus à Marseille sont toujours dans
les rues toujours à faire des choses
pour les autres c'est génial parce que
ce qu'il a fait le sans-abris il va
pouvoir concentrer dedans il a rien pour
transporter il a pas de maison il y a
donc il va pouvoir plier le maximum dans
une petite capacité s'isoler du froid
c'est précieux ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
énorme c'est phénoménal